good kid hello everybody it's the third
stream of the day it's red for reason
behind us that is because as mentioned
earlier we're playing Wolfenstein to the
new Colossus I'm reading that title here
let me don't say the Newark so for those
of you who can hear some stuff in the
background this is just kind of a recap
of what happened both with the sign the
new order those you that played it
you obviously know what happens with DES
head and kind of like the whole story
behind it but the game opens with that
we we didn't want you guys to miss
ending the cinematic we decided to start
you don't have to see any of this okay
so just real quick that's Nick if you
didn't see in the lower third I'm Eric
just to give you a heads up right now
obviously Wolfenstein to assign to the
whole time so you can call Wolfenstein
change I want to say it is a single
player game heavy story base we're gonna
start from the very beginning you have
seen the first mission which is the
wheelchair mission but I want to give
the heads up right now spoilers ahead
major spoilers within the first five
minutes you know if you don't want to be
here for spoilers I totally understand
we are not upset that your guys are
leaving i I do appreciate all you guys
being here in that the chat with us
joining us and tuning in with us I'm
almost afraid
Nick I almost want to give it like
another minute or two for people to file
in so that I can give the spoiler
disclaimer because boiler spoiler
spoiler spoiler spoiler no use all team
guys have seen a fair amount of this
there's big spoilers right off the bat
so I just want to get it out there so
that you guys know and that there's
nothing stopping us so here we go
I suppose Nick alright I'm gonna go
ahead and skip previously on because we
all know what yessum for those of you
who are still around and want to stick
around but uh alright let's see I don't
know the name is just I keep looking at
that screen it says hope inside the new
order clearly it's not well consigned to
the new Colossus
here we go here we go Sochi
your father won't be home tonight
business over in Dallas oh boy he hurt
you so bad just rest and heal I have
soup and partage which one would you
like
so for those of you who remember you
have to make a choice who dies
I saved white the first time so go ahead
and continue why it's time line
[Music]
around my friends that love out fire and
the great warmth washing over me I think
the sky's on fire
we'll need a gurney it's a hang of
things at the gates again Allen money
let's get some long-haired homebody
sorry I made you wait Milani let me show
you something Billy my father told me if
I ever have this son I should give this
to him it is an engagement ring it has
been with our family for eight
generations
can't you imagine that's Billy it is
what they call an heirloom when you meet
someone special
you'll place this ring on her finger it
is worth a lot of history do not tell
your father about this dream he will
take it he does not know about it you
know how he is
mother my acquitted was a righteous and
just good enough to witness the earth
heaven
no that's not warnings for language I'm
gonna have to cut most of his intestines
out I just ate lunch in there Sophia out
of my way he does not deserve this you
know he does not don't [ __ ] me
I saw him with her
he knows god damn well not to spend time
with some dirty little [ __ ] girl not
anymore
you have no idea what it's like to
suffer like I do Oh Sophia every day I'm
out there busting my ass tooth and nail
getting screwed out of my earnings left
and right humiliating myself just to
keep the business alive I saw them two
together Sophia getting sweet with each
other under the poplar tree this cannot
happen I have worked too hard for too
damn long to lose my reputation cuz my
boy is sweet on some [ __ ] I cook I
clean I tend to the stables to the field
you should have sucked down the business
when my father told you to behind it
everything three months behind in
utility all the money my father invested
you have lost you are playing with fire
Sofia what are you doing I am NOT the
man you want to mouth off to and you are
not the man I married
I'm Eddie two men we'd never let his
family go hungry so help me I will not
will not let you hurt my son you shut
your damn mouth before I shut it for you
what is it with you damned Jews have all
the answers do you smart mouth god damn
Jew I married you I figured you fathered
be an asset but you just a damn
millstone sticking your nose into my bed
and instead of handling your own if you
can't raise the boy right I'll do it
oh no you don't mess with the dog oh oh
[Music]
not faced that face they're gonna pick
on you they will break you they will
make you eat dirt and what are you gonna
do about it
you can't fight to save your life really
at least I can teach him so BJ's having
these flashbacks of his family life
because he's recover your strength big
plans are in motion the tides are
turning
it's a Christ out circle he's rising I
feel need you by my side let me make a
move yeah that's the dinner time you
ain't going nowhere whimper all you want
now you got to make hard decisions
and sometimes you got to punish the
animals out there
it's kill or be killed the old and the
weak are doomed all manner of scum and
sick minds bodies cockroaches doing
everything in their power to rob the
white man of what he's earned it's on us
to straighten out the queer it's on you
finger on the trigger
oh no never did you shoot him any what's
this on the blood I thought I could turn
him Oh subtitles I will shut it turn him
on next next time I see some it will end
better
kind of takes off where you're fine the
ìiî top-down all right you want to turn
on subtitles
uh yeah let me run this okay and I will
turn them on for sure
I just run you catheter oh we haven't
walked in like hella long
set will tell you how long nice
all right wheel chair Billy let me turn
on the subtitles for you guys Oh see all
right we got the we got the subs come in
sorry about that
thought we were it only gives you for
the German apparently so so again we're
early here very early on DS this is a
kind of already been seen right this
part so ah this has yeah boilers ahead
just so you guys know thanks for the gun
so you guys will notice I only have 50
percent help 15 now but the maximum is
50 okay and because he's obviously the
man he used to be so this part is a
little difficult sure uh just quick ones
for you guys in chat I've lowered the
game played down a little bit here just
so that we don't get drowned out by the
gameplay but hit me up oh you know what
ammo is in the bottom right so what do
you think bottom left or top left where
do you think I should
[Music]
top left is probably good ok I gotta
move the top left eventually fair with
you guys so the gameplay is a little
funky here because you're obviously in a
wheelchair but that's I mean like they
should try to send me like that right a
little bit yeah yeah no that's kind of
cool watch watch these do you guys this
is cool
so we got a cutscene coming up here okay
come
all right so you guys can see set has
built these microwave traps he said
now mr. blaster which I'm very happy to
see you awake not so how say you Arthur
where is she last time I saw she was she
was with Caroline defending the cell
platform elevator then point me in that
direction you know how long you've been
in bed five months
hey girl five months your body is broken
baraka understand kidneys are failing
you you might have difficulties to to
urinate to use your schmeckle
[Music]
Nazis reach the u-bahn many idiots they
don't know they'll finish them China he
said help me find the sale platform
elevator my suction action such an
action
ok now that many Nazis between here and
the same platform elevator bot I said
several traps I didn't have the time to
activate them but look at this this is a
map to show me where the traps up chaps
are cool but they're really difficult
cuz they'll kill you too you forgot you
turn one on yeah they will make you into
mush yeah Cory I'll be monitoring chat
Nick is playing he's played a little bit
I put about 2 hours
yeah 2 hours calm it is a very
interesting game and it is pretty
difficult to be honest we're not on an
Xbox 1x Chris Christ offer we are just
Christopher probably we're just playing
on an Xbox you have a nest there that's
this is an S yeah this isn't us so as
you can see I just lured a couple Nazis
into sets traps I know there's one here
who killed me last time
interesting all right so look at you
waiting this guy turn set strap off so
once you go down the stairs now you have
someone else saying no subtitles they
ruin the gameplay I mean usually better
for streaming in case you guys can't
hear something so when is this coming
out a swine burger is coming out Friday
October 27 it'll probably the 26th like
at 9:00 p.m. is my guess if when the
East Coaster well that's also the day
one
Mario artists I got you you just worry
about gaming until I send you some
questions word I'm just playing yeah you
got you got the sticks right now maximum
focus
sorry I'm not a over-the-top YouTube
where someone was like these guys are
kind of like you know not as excitable
Wow sometimes we just want to let the
game speak for its and we also don't
want to ruin this the cutscenes cuz
they're very pretty
yeah they're pretty emotional you tell
me obviously a lot of interactable girls
Rita Bulls hold the map yeah is there
multiple right new leaf so this is some
Friday to remember that is correct in
the kurus sunny yeah easy
oh my god
and today we had destiny to PC launch as
well so playing that a little bit
actually just before this dream was
getting used to that control setup with
mouse keyboard but yeah this one's gonna
be also very great on the on the PC
we're actually hoping to stream PC today
but we just haven't gotten our PC code
yet yep so that actually worked out in
Nick's favor because now he gets to play
wolf well it works out my favor and also
doesn't work out my favorite because I
was 2 hours in I wanted to keep going
start over that's why hey you're doing
it for the stream I figured it would be
better for you guys to see from the
beginning right instead of like us an
hour in and then people not
understanding where we're at because at
least now we can say like okay spoilers
right and also not have to explain what
happened in the beginning so you've
either been along for the ride and want
to see it or not
yeah but again this portion is kind of
in seeing the wheelchair part so we're
currently on an Xbox at 1's a slim um we
don't have the X yet
set strap on here and then I'm gonna try
to lure a couple them lay back tap I'm
not sure how long the campaign is uh if
we think watch him what do you think
like 10 to 12 or was how long was a new
order was about 12 hours so maybe 12
plus them in that in that area so I I
would expect it to be a little longer
and we'll see
I think it'll I think this is a trilogy
so we know also gonna be interested in
seeing some of the other Bethesda games
come out on switch might not necessarily
look if the prettiest on that console
but it's gonna be great for portability
like Dumon things like that yeah I don't
um you played do right yes I did do you
want switch it's cool it's I mean some
switch so it's definitely toned down a
bit yeah graphics wise but that's not to
knock it the fact that I can brain on
the bus yeah and play it while I'm on my
commute yep
have that sweet metal music same same
with this like ie
realistically I don't see myself playing
a game like this on anything other in PC
or console versus like this yeah but it
it is a cool it is a cool game and it is
a cool concept to be able to take this
with me devil dog oh the dog that you
shot in YouTube chat just kidding right
yeah says that the game is said to last
12 to 15 hours so yep make sense alright
apparently yeah a lot of people are
saying answering cyborg man's question
which is what years is said in there
saying 1960's 19 see one so yeah all
right mayor belt let's do it you get to
America bunch of Nazis on the way he has
the red colored Xbox 1s I have the Gears
of War the Gears of War
oh no reverse to convey about haha BJ
what we do now that your wheelchairs
basically not anymore
giving here and I gotta crawl into it so
he's always seen a lot of pain for those
of you don't remember you know the sound
platform big thing in the last game I
guess head obviously set up the grenade
when you try to kill him at the end yeah
so that's why you are severely wounded
but now for five months very you know
who is tarah Billy is even real
they're a ton of Nazis down here hey
what's up and it's hard to like go in an
attic cover this wheelchair you need to
have opposed to be it's supposed to give
you the feeling of like what it would be
like if you are in a wheelchair having
to kill whoa hello Vijay is just a beast
for me being able just one hand this not
to mention he he's been asleep
well not asleep pretty much in a coma
which is funny because it's the second
game in a row where Vijay's like in a
coma for quite some time and has to wake
up and immediately go to war dark Psalm
2 v 9 a.m. Battlefront 2 beta why didn't
you cut off the stream
I don't know I didn't cut we didn't cut
off any of the streams particularly
literally in a certain way we just ended
the stream as normal usually go for
about 60 to 90 minutes sometimes longer
gamespot no co-op no multiplayer guys
new if you are a DJ and oh shoot I don't
even see them good you got environmental
killing you didn't even mean it that's
the best what's up mmm kale mix plan
I'll be monitoring YouTube chat twitch
chat games bla check you guys have
questions I'll try to send them Nick's
way it's played for about 2 hours
initial initial reactions because I do
want to share those yeah sure this is a
direct continuation that feels good it
really does it like in terms of story in
terms of story like I am everything that
I've been wondering for who knows how
long just starting to get in it is like
starting to get answered slowly but
surely and it feels oh so good he's here
press
so we're rerouting the conveyor belt all
right how does he scare with one hand
when shooting because he's the boss boss
he's BJ blaskowitz oh hello
so Frau angle the woman who's out very
early is here I will activate louder so
you guys have seen some of this man
complaint for the Xbox version I don't
think on PC there's that pause thanks
dark storm
I'll burn
don't be stupid okay
let's get you up damn she's pregnant
you've gotten so fat that says we're
having twins
here comes set to ruin the moment let's
get you outside onto the deck clothes
killing him
growling
is that girl Caroline
oh here she is lost us no smash
that's growing with the dawn
push hard knows what's going on
so they're taking Wyatt
[Music]
core warning you've been warned yeah
and we're coming up on uncharted
territory for you guys your week William
you're in no shape to fight
I grew Thandi in the comments for you I
love how they hide growling those face
you don't see the scholar said yeah you
going to run us over with your little
wheelchair
[Music]
love to me I came for you
at night it's coming back you think
you're here Joseph still think of it
for those asking were ashamed from sixty
to ninety days let me tell you not only
the degenerate breads of the slum admire
you the fizzy drinks festering and the
ghetto but once they see you change
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
she is one of the most terrifying
villains what was the point of saving
[Music]
no I so colonics women are bomb bombs
that's apt to see it running cancer you
know at our poker sleep must receive a
fine
yeah
leader of the
the criminal mastermind never give up
his courage never give it to these
people I think that
I think you're just another
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh No Oh God
Wyatt get in the armor flask oh yeah
that's gonna do something
all right so four angles escaping
oh look Wyatt what a badass damn I
didn't see that coming so why cut his
ear cut for those of you have seen some
of the other cutscenes with the Fergus
timeline I'm pretty sure he gets his arm
cut off not positive look at Wyatt what
a guy
[Music]
so we have to first detach the u-boat
ship right from her grasps here we go
got the power Armour all right so the
power armors got a pretty cool thing so
I jump up and slam my feet down I can go
through the floor in some places it also
is 200 armor which is good because BJ is
really hurt oh why it has major plot
armor yeah why it is yeah someone was
saying they kind of confirm what you
said about a third yeah so yeah that's
what I assumed I just like how like why
it's like please power armor guy stop
why it isn't interesting how did that
guy not strangle him in like one go
sorry anyways here's your first look at
the new stealth kills sorry I don't
think you're walking ever again poor
Caroline it sucks
I really liked her character too but I I
am a should to see because I haven't met
the new leader from all the trailers
it's gonna be interesting
it's weird I'm hitting the different
button they scream very loudly again
their legs chopped up yeah and here we
go
so there are two confidence here that's
the power armor only for this mission um
someone's asking so or maybe we don't
spoil if you know I'm about I'm about
two hours in and I still have it isn't
that a dude right there that you just
passed where's your left
oh shoot Thanks I was like I'm really
close I need to kill the other how come
you didn't get a sick stealth kill there
I don't know that was weird I have
noticed a couple buggy things it's not
really a big deal sometimes when I'm
trying to go through the floor
I'll get stuck but I'm sure those just
be day one patches yeah so I want to
make sure I killed a confidant before I
start killing these others because I
don't want him to signal I don't know
where he is
he might be below me well one guy just
walked by I don't know yeah those are
just soldiers I want the confidant last
time I played he was just standing over
heated areas kill him what was that
weapons hot
yeah there are many different ways
people play this game
I know Cali play who's gonna be
reviewing the game is uh plays it very
stealth heavy I don't have the patience
go guns blazing because it's fun is good
and you reload so much faster now or
maybe I'm just thinking you do I have
from playing overwatch I reload like
after every show hidden I know it's a
really bad habit especially for cod
considering you want to do some Lumbee
ones against we cod World War two get
ready it's the chamber we got we got
some hot games right now it's time to as
yeah I know I shouldn't be yeah we were
just currently playing on normal for
those asking there's there is a what our
difficulty slider so you can play
however you want
yep but you know for the sake of the
stream and just having Nick be able to
talk and play I think normals fine so I
had a trouble getting through that
little hole last time which was weird I
couldn't he like wouldn't go down I
think it was a little it'll be day one
stuff I'm sure okay crispy saying
stealth is only fun in Metal Gear
yeah there are certain games that
stealth is more satisfying but this game
definitely has some really good stuff
parts but you don't have to now the
Nazis know where I am though so if you
guys didn't know we are playing we'll
just assign to the new Colossus fighting
a play for I spend about 45 ish minutes
now I'll probably go for another 30 plus
minutes let's uh let's try to get off
this thing and back down to the u-boat
sounds good I'm just giving the stream
the image of like how much time we might
go 45 I'm like those up full 90 here we
can stream up to like a certain point
but we don't want to spoil too much we
just want to show you some of the early
gameplay get you guys feel for the game
look at the game the beginning story if
you guys have requests for specific
gameplay I'm gonna be taking care of
that this week yeah so let me know what
you guys are above the scene I want to
see a hot like stealth kill montage it's
on to your left the thing oh really
why would you play this game stealthy oh
there is like a skill tree that kind of
or like is not necessarily sketchy
that's not white there are certain so
this time around they have all shits
grenade
so this time around there's a couple
things called contraptions so we've
revealed in some gameplay Clips a couple
of contraptions yeah so one of them is
the ability to run through walls
juggernaut pretty much yeah that's
that's what it should be called and you
can explode Nazis right yeah in certain
areas if you sprint into Nazi Hill look
then there's other ones so that one is
obviously not stealth you've never used
that in the self situation so there's
that one and confidant
how are you then there's another one
that's how to describe skills so it
allows you to get to higher positions
higher ground easily then there's a
third one that that's the stealth and so
the stealth allows you to crawl through
pikes it allows you to like kind of
Howard it's like this weird Nazi
technology I'm think that lets you kind
of like that control
squash yourself down into like small
areas
yes you can play this game without style
cloth very much so
all right let's release that you vote
that's you book
box office
all right breath
and they just reinitiated
so it quickly dips and they're all
coming just because it's me
like what I'm saying is why can't she
just read tether so I guess you just
turn it off shut up max
[Music]
they're gonna get inside to submerge
so oh yeah you got act listen PJ is
obviously really really hurt you see the
wheelchair he's using a super suit that
Caroline used because she was paralyzed
I believe to Eva's hammer and I'm
heading back to our people I hate to ask
please stick around because I can keep
your minds along with a super soldier
whoa you do that laughter I played oh my
goodness gracious that's sorry ahead
pain users for his loud yell because
even I heard it in mine in that thicket
hurt so good luck to you guys that's
scared me
these are new weapons on their pocket
otters don't kill them
what a what a protip sorry headphone
users that scared the bejesus out of me
right now
he dropped a weapon this is another
thing that happened a laser where laser
get away that's good
sure
it wasn't that loud okay good okay maybe
it's just Kurt Mike please do that
another super-soldier it is i mean his
body into mush are you only have one
hundred seven more
it's like kilowatts or jw8 it is its
kilowatts so these are entered so like
new order these are the energy the new
energy weapon
one of the new
like I said guys you guys can play on
the difficulty of your choosing
thanks somewhere what they said oh
nothing they're just saying like protip
play on easy which is just normal oh
yeah funny thing is I'm in an elitist
gamer but like I don't ever tell people
the difficulty they should play on they
should play on what they let's go ahead
and charge this baby PC versions
probably the way to go if your PC can
handle it I think yeah not totally good
yeah I'm interested to play this on I
have a Playstation order that I have
coming and I'm interested to see if
there's any difference notice let's go
to top deck
I will try to do this a little step and
I just watch you do this part new you
just looked similar outside
oh I'm going to try to sneak to the
other confidant okay but if not I'm
gonna run back to that that gun and just
lay waste to the big ones
I just wouldn't like crispy is a mass
kiss and look maybe I should specify
isn't a masochist but says loves the
challenge of insane load yeah some
people definitely play the games for the
challenge that was different
I still like to chop both legs off yeah
I did taste pretty gruesome he I need to
go get that other big ones are over here
like it oh oh my cat uh-oh I was trying
to kill the confidante before I needed
to go back and get this bad boy but I
need it because there's to the super
soldiers up here okay and these things
lay waste
nice good work
where is he you're like where is he all
right pick up some ammo that's another
thing like the moon level you can pick
up ammo energy ammo don't say you missed
50 armor I didn't see it though yeah I
left it because I wanted to see how much
armor I lost during this area yeah I'll
go back and get it now I think I just
killed around you thank you that beam
cannon says toast Man X yeah it's a
laser wigger that's better than where I
would say all right tea man will 195s
what's the essential to play after the
campaign's over
you just find different ways to play I
would assume or different difficulties
harder difficulties like I ended up all
do might be slightly different but like
for me when I played doom when I beat
the campaign I went back and got
collectibles I did like I was messing
around with different weapons upgrading
different weapons there's what upgrading
there's also a two-time look right so
you have the fergus timeline you have
the Wyatt timeline so you can go ahead
and go with either or true what else I
mean it's probably just for me it's like
doing the two timelines yeah I mean like
I said what you do eventually have
weapon upgrades and we don't even know
if you'll have enough points to spend it
all so maybe it'll change your gameplay
depending on yeah you upgrade your
weapons or like a contraption I know
after speaking with a couple of devs to
the game and I'm at one of those like
meetings that they told me that there
wouldn't really be the opportunity to
have all three contraptions at the same
time okay so that means that you might
have to pick one stealthy you might
to pick one to go you know up in the air
you might want to pick the escape pod I
just checked that gun all right let's
have to go but one last thing hold up
oh she's still there oh that's awkward
you know you don't continue do you
continue that use the armor for a while
yeah yeah we don't know I don't know we
don't know if there's an upgrade but I
don't think so I think something happens
I have a theory about yeah if anyone
wants to tell me their theories in the
comments this is so sad they think it's
about 12 to 15 hours what someone
mentioned earlier in terms of the
so the crew
[Music]
she obviously played a major to liberate
the United States of America to free the
US and use it as a platform to liberate
the rest of the world and this is what
we are going to do for Caroline can we
trust her policy scepticism hello give
her a chance I guess she saved my life
she saved captain blaskowitz too now
Caroline had established radio contact
with an American resistance group in New
York and our first priority is to set
course for New York go let's go around
three but how
Regis has been receiving messages that's
impossible
someone surprises there is a section F
mock's are no accurate we've looked and
there's no door there what if there is
what if someone is hiding in there
transmitting that signal huh
cap you assemble a team investigators
must be there inside the boat and
they've been inside the boat since we
took it in the last game this is a mind
F for me
what do you see 12 the shot from the
other side you can take this Wyatt came
up with a basic concept the design is
like a guy gets experimental but it will
be very useful you said kill Nazis
enthusiastically so sure well hurry up
so do you want to keep going or yeah
yeah okay yeah we don't leave in an hour
we'll go for another half an hour maybe
get through half of this like how long
do you think this mission is Oh will you
stop whatever yeah that's mine let's
just go so this gun you shoot something
they're mine and then use the other
trigger to blow it up nitrous cool okay
that's new Famers asking how's the game
so far guys from what I've been watching
I think it's awesome
Nick would have a better gauge in that
way because I haven't actually played
myself this story is everything I've
wanted so far
Tom Franco asking are the playthroughs
distinct enough to warrant a second one
I mean like it's mainly for story as
Nick said in terms of two storylines I
mean the gameplay you can kind of change
up a little bit for yourself through
probably like different mods that you're
gonna put on your gun potentially and
also the contraptions because we're not
it sounded like you wouldn't be able to
get all three contraptions so you might
want to mess around contraptions the
second time around
Oh was that right in the in the cojones
don't man what's we doing this with a
review out on GameSpot it'll probably
come later this week who's reviewing
this it's gonna be Callie
Maggie Callie just got done Callie just
got done playing all of new order and
old blood over again so she was like
fully and mentally machine after slicin
you wouldn't write oh nobody went for
the cones man armor Beckett I don't know
I totally so how many of these guys were
in your boat this whole time like what
the hell all right just been chilling
they've been inside the boat in a secret
compartment that's how big this u-boat
is oh hey what up oh thanks um oh the
back part of it right in in the jugular
is is I am very excited to see what miss
Callie
[ __ ] doing work he's doing work on
these Nazis man turns out this section
was a lot bigger than we thought brow is
still bombing the book yeah she should
be
[Music]
how much gameplay are you guys allowed
to show technically we could go pretty
far like in the ended like I think I say
the embargo is like chapter 5 but a
decent chunk of just setting up the
story so I'm gonna try to get through
this mission I don't know if we will but
that's the what we're gonna try to do
and then we'll probably call it a stream
it's been a crazy day we did Assassin's
Creed origins earlier this morning if
you missed that me and Jake check that
out no story spoilers and that one as we
were able to kind of do some free
roaming exploration but obviously woman
signed to the new Colossus is all story
based so it's hard for us to stream this
and not kind of spoil some stuff at the
top of the hour I kind of did preface
that and warm people glad you guys are
the the folks that are still here
willing to tune in and hang out with us
ask some questions have some
conversations go some Nazis need that
confidence come down these stairs okay
can't play wait to play it when is it
coming out it should be Thursday at 9
p.m. Pacific 12800 that's his foot it's
like here take all this and then I want
you to watch me cut you in the head
that's good
I couldn't resist I know that's fine
they're starving
they've been in here for five months I
got some pretty it's some wet when do
you get the hot dual-wield action I
could do a wheel right now if you want
oh well then yeah I just love reloading
though mister true story yeah a good
story though alternate timeline 1960s I
would say if you didn't play the first
one that you should at least oh you get
caught up a little bit but you should
probably play it probably can't be that
expensive now I bought the combo
recently which came with old blood and
the new order and it was only $30 in the
PlayStation Store no confidant
Williams I'm picking up a Peter Brown
we'll be doing our Mario Mario Odyssey
I'll come later this week as well expect
a Mario Odyssey stream with Peter and
eventually I might just put Peter and
Robb together because they've been
playing that game so my just make yeah
runs that one even though I normally do
help host most of our streams but
sometimes in those cases it makes a lot
more sense to have two knowledgeable hey
is this one folks lately all right Zane
where's that hard to say I didn't
actually play a thousand feet myself but
if you're into the Assassin's Creed
universe already and wanted somebody
takes on it I think it does scratch
those itches again it is part of Mac a
lot of stuff is coming out I know that
it's tough that for for people to buy
all of those games let alone have all
those platforms so you know I would say
pick the one that you think you're gonna
have the most fun with if you've been
fortunate enough or blessed enough to be
able to buy more than one game great you
know enjoy those games you got all
holiday sometimes you know a good
strategy is to kind of like buy the one
you really want to play first kind of
wait it out and some of those games like
you know month or two later they've been
going on discount I mean like I even saw
this destiny to at some point like
really already it was 30 bucks Wow yeah
a console so that might have been a
limited time deal but you know check
that out or be patient sometimes being
patient is pretty awesome but definitely
there are some games that are worth
buying day one and will last you
potentially for a while yeah this very
story driven game so I feel like if you
don't want to have the story ruined for
you this might be the game you want to
start with if this is something that
you're passionate about
but other than that he's here I'm trying
to I'm trying to catch up
Donny JEP thanks for the kind words I
don't think you're close enough to the
office to come hang out but you know
thanks for tuning in
hope you enjoy the stream how's it come
to an end yet we're still going strong
here try to get through this mission try
to clear out the Nazis that are in our
u-boat so we can get stop getting bombed
and they're clearly very loyal because
they're willing to get blown up in the
same u-boat for the prowl Oh
wasn't her skill tree for you and for
you to even show yet hello Oh
should be dead from that gloves
Garos technically right all right no
more Frau angle Oh what apparently I
missed all right
if I can shoot it do I have anything
bigger Oh
bingo is that grenade launcher way to go
burgers B I think their burgers it yeah
burgers be damned this looks good it
does look pretty good
whoa what was that oh it's a grenade
shoot I was like what is that so I guess
I can throw back from nades already well
you're pretty weak here so just FYI god
you're an alternate then ain't gonna
help overnights
okay you got to do life I just
Oh while you're taking big beeps now
it's hurt is doing work
yeah it's hurt stuff I need to get
around
nice work well another guys coming up I
don't know if he behind you and there's
a guy oh no that's cool guy recover
close the armor nice yeah dad a couple
I don't think a Dreamcast can read this
but you know you can try if you want to
vodka you shoot the box oh yeah home
rush to death later yeah we did we did
do that
boom burst away he said 1 rush those
death laser oh yeah
goop was saying self was ope in the last
one hope it's more balanced this time
round uh it's pretty balanced I've
struggled to like sneak I mentioned
Lubitz said something about question
goob you asked a question earlier I
forgot all it was yeah just keep going I
saw and I meant to answer you but I go
tree yeah we'll check out that if we can
yeah we can do that to end how's the
frame we're like this is xbox so it
seems okay but I think it'll probably be
significant time significantly improved
on PC
alright yum yum he said shut up Eric
all right so we'll watch this cutscene
and we'll try to check out of the steel
gym
let's go
everyone is gathered
[Music]
the funeral
she just happened to have another outfit
who the daughter like that
what daughter House daughter she changed
her it Oh all they've known all they
felt all the [ __ ] they've gone through
all of it God
like it never was
yeah come in captain warm at the service
why I just look I couldn't do it okay
it's too much Caroline meant more to me
than anybody else on this damn ship and
now everyone is expecting me to pick up
the torch all right
yeah I mean look at me man I can't even
find a pair of headphones all right it
feels the leadership course at Harvard
for pete's sake I know I didn't hear
somewhere where the heck are they we'll
just winging nuts stop for Christ's sake
you can't give up why we don't do this
I'm not stupid
captain I saw the look in your eye up
there when Franco had you under her
thumb
all right the fire is going out and you
were just an autopilot now until you hit
the wall am I wrong captain
thank God I am i salvaged some stuff at
J's you know from TV Ezra Luce from the
last game he was like Jimi Hendrix just
that boy could play the guitar
hey captain would you go see Seth he
wants to give you a physical or
something you know just see how you're
doing
think he's in his workshop
this is actually where I stopped so
we've connected before that I was know
so let's see if yeah in question for you
before you do this country so I wanted
to know if there's collectibles in the
levels there are I haven't found any I
found a lot of things that I can read
that are really really interesting like
there was a letter I skipped all that
just because of time purposes for this
um but there was a letter from one of
the Nazis that was hiding underneath
enemies talking about how terrorists had
taken over the boat and how he was like
you didn't know if he would see his
family again makes you kind of like
humanized the Nazis that are on the boat
it's really crazy okay but I haven't
seen anything like the gold stuff in the
past games because it was like gold
items in new order gold just gold bars
in the old blood I haven't seen any
alright I don't see it at all yeah okay
so normally it would be in this yeah if
you had the ability so I know for a fact
that once I got when I played kind of
deeper in one of the demos with Bethesda
you go into the options menu it was here
okay this is all normal game play stuff
I'll leave it right here on this
American flag sounds good alright just
want to say thank you guys all for
tuning in that was about an hour and
fifteen minutes of the beginning of
Wolfenstein to the new Colossus comes
out this Thursday night a.m. depending
on how you look at it and I promise ya
27 9 p.m. Pacific PI for us which is 12
Eastern look forward to the review from
Kali at the end of the week but yeah
your your liking it so far from what you
played yeah really you guys have seen
everything that I have seen so far so
you guys can judge as much as I can I
think it looks really good I'm really
enjoying it the gameplay feels good the
cutscenes look beautiful it's a direct
continuation of a story that we thought
was done we thought BJ was dead so this
is cool yeah and also just as a reminder
some people are asking like Assassin's
Creed or this obviously that's gonna
depend on how much one you can spend
which series have you played longer what
kind of gameplay do you want so I think
that's tough for us to tell you what to
buy but we did play Assassin's Creed
origins for about also an hour this
morning me and Jake we're just free
roaming checking out Egypt doing some
cool stuff so you can check that out
kind of try to make a decision for
yourself or wait for the reviews to come
out also under to review for Assassin's
Creed will be out later this week as
well and of course Mario is gonna be out
later this week as well Peters review
all pi be coming later this week and
we'll probably streaming that as well so
feed into that when we do that if you
haven't hit that follow like and
subscribe please do that cuz that'll
help notify you as to when we go live
with some of these cool games that
sometimes we get to stream early like
Wolfenstein 2 in Assassin's Creed
origins but we really appreciate you
guys all tuning in today and until
tomorrow on the lobby 11:00 a.m. Pacific
me and Nick we'll see you next time
thanks for tuning in bye guys